okay so it's time to take a trip to
selfie world we announced the recent
grand opening of the interactive
diy photography studio in town square
just last week and of course
we had to go and see it for ourselves
rocky theas is there live to show us how
to utilize the space and of course
get that perfect shot right
[Music]
that is right christian okay so this is
one of the areas here and there are
22 booths in all of selfie world here in
vegas it's their biggest one
to date and we get it right here at town
square so i have a few pictures that i
took
if you could pop those up so i could
show off my skills a little bit
just because i had a lesson from the few
gen zeros okay those are the ones who
you know the trendsetters the cool ones
the young ones that we have to learn
from
so thank you so much for joining us
kaylee who is a local influencer
and marissa who's her cousin and her
photographer okay this is teamwork this
is a family
affair here so we want to talk about
because we talked about lighting
and how important that is in the last
one and they every time you come in and
you make a reservation
you get a ring light to take with you
around the place so that's really cool
and then of course the next thing are
angles right
how important are angles and how do you
do it come set us up um
okay so there's like multiple angles
that you can take pictures from i
usually just base it on their poses
and like what flatters their like the
way they look and like
things like that but lighting is really
hard
because like as you can see that sign
like if i go over here
right so you want to be careful when
there's a neon sign with the ring light
because the reflection gets in the way
right so like if i take a picture i can
show you ooh look at that can you see
the
perfect so like you can see it on the
the sign and that's like not something
you want it can like mess up the picture
interesting and with this one i like i
like this booth in particular because
it has the the gate right or the the
cell so this
the bars actually kind of creates a
really cool angle right yeah
so if i wanted to take a picture from
that angle i would move the led light or
the ring right you guys are getting a
personal lesson here from jinzy right
now okay this is rare
i would take the picture and i have the
settings customized
on my phone so i have it at a 16-3 ratio
and then plus three exposure to like
brighten up the picture
so it's not so dim okay are you guys
taking notes seriously okay come on come
over here you guys because i wanna show
another
another booth that kind of gives you a
different perspective kaylee and i are
gonna sit down
here as the models okay and this is a
two this is a pair
shot but marissa has a secret to getting
the shot
and it has to do with video not still
photo right right so explain that
concept
okay so the camera on your phones
takes good pictures but in videos it's
in 4k
okay so you get a better quality photo
and live photos are way easier to take
in a video
portion like in a video wow look at and
look how
look at the position okay she is
squatting this is hard work
you make your you make your cousin and
your photographer work for you girl oh
yes
for like an hour and a half last time
i feel like this is a sport coming into
selfie world you got to be a little
athletic to get these angles and these
and these photos right
so what she said if you didn't hear you
do your photos on a video
and then you screenshot the video for
your favorite shots
right because when it's still photos
you're stuck with the one face with the
video you could be mid pose and you like
it better than the actual pose wow
so that's what we do and it just we get
a bunch more pictures that way
oh my gosh look mind blown okay i'm
taking all the notes coming up later in
the four o'clock though
we want to show off not just the photo
booth here but also the really great
story too so stay tuned for that
right and rocky before you go christian
producer adriana and i want to know how
many pictures have you taken so far
oh my gosh to way too many i'm
embarrassed
all right way too many we'll check back
with her in a little bit christian